after days of searching by air and sea
crews found this debris in waters near
the island of bali
a torpedo launch pipe a bottle with
grease sponges and even what appears to
be a prayer mat
this debris is crucial evidence but also
cause for concern
with the discovery of evidence of
equipment from the submarine
this is the proof that there are cracks
in the submarine
due to heavy pressure the kri nangala
402 was initially classified as missing
authorities now say they are certain it
sank
crews found an oil spill with a radius
of 16 kilometers in the search area
and the vessel could be lying as deep as
850 meters below the ocean's surface
exceeding what the submarine was built
to withstand
53 people were on board experts say it's
very unlikely any have survived
my information my experience would say
the time for searching is passed
the time for hoping for rescue has
passed
now is the time to understand what
happened
indonesian navy ships are on the scene
and other countries including australia
singapore and the u.s are assisting with
the search
days after the submarine lost contact
indonesian authorities say they are
committed to finding it
and trying to start the evacuation
process but they warn it will be risky
and complicated when the search began
navy officials said
if there had been a total power outage
on board the crew only had
enough oxygen to last 72 hours
that time has now passed
we cannot say how the victims are
because we haven't found them until now
so the conditions of the victims cannot
be determined
the submarine was built in the late
1970s
and completed a two-year refit in south
korea in 2012.
now after 40 years the kri nangala 402
has made its final journey and the
family and friends of those on board
are waiting to know what happened to
their loved ones
jessica washington al jazeera jakarta